let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right number one today of course is
the 19th anniversary of 9 11 a good time
to pray for our country there's never a
bad time never a bad day or bad time but
today in particular is good for that um
i don't have much commentary to offer on
9 11 19 years out except to wonder aloud
to ask the same question i guess that so
many people
ask as these anniversaries roll around
and that is
if there was another 911 i mean a real
another 911
you know things are always claimed to be
the next 911 or the new
911 or another 911 but i'm talking about
something that
that really matches that in terms of the
magnitude and something that
weighs on the national consciousness in
the same way to the same extent
if that happened again when it happens
again
would we be capable as a nation of
unifying
even briefly in the face of it
as everyone always those of us who lived
through it um i was
i don't know 13 or 14 i think when 9 11
happened and
um those of us who lifted we talk all
the time about how
the nation seemed unified in the direct
aftermath
of of the the terrorist attack i think i
think we probably overstate just how
unified we probably
in our minds emotionally overstate and
exaggerate it
um especially those of us who were kids
when it happened
you know but there's no question that
there was a real sense of unity it
didn't last for very long but it was
there
and i you wonder could could we if there
was a 911 like tomorrow
would there be even one day of everybody
on the same side or would it be
boom immediately we're politicizing it
blaming each other putting fingers and
everything
that's the question i'm not going to get
much into my answer because my answer is
very depressing uh
my answer is basically no but let's not
harp on that today
let's move on number two biden spokesman
tj ducklow who perhaps
more than anyone else in politics looks
like his name
appeared on fox yesterday and became
very evasive and seemingly flummoxed
over extremely basic
questions about the candidate and his
positions
uh listen to this says joe biden ever
used a teleprompter during local
interviews
or to answer q a with supporters brett
we are not going to engage this is
this is straight from the trump campaign
exactly they're using it and what it
does
and what it does brett is it's trying to
distract the american people i'm just
they're using it they talk about it
every day can you say yes or no that's
because they talk about it every day
brad because they don't have
a coherence well you have to answer yes
or no
brett they talk about it every day
because they don't have a coherent
argument for why donald trump deserves
re-election
deserves four more years we know that he
lied to the american people we know that
he has not
uh shown leadership during this crisis
and they are desperate to throw anything
they can against the wall to try to
distract from that fact i understand but
you can't answer the question
brett i am not going to allow a trump
campaign to funnel their questions
through fox news
and get me to respond to that well tj we
appreciate your time and thank you for
coming on
thanks brett i love the tone he takes
when he's asked a very basic question
so it's like tj is the sun hot
now brett brett now brett brett now
brett
right that's a republican talking point
no i just want to know if the sun is hot
brett now hey brett come on brett
that's you got to stop with the gotcha
questions but really
this is a reflection i think of the fact
that tj ducklow and friends
um and by the way ducklow and friends
should be the name of a children's show
on
nick jr but ducklow and friends they
spend most of their time in the cnn
msnbc left-wing media orbit and are
simply
never asked any challenging questions at
all of any kind
on the rare occasion that they get a
real question they are permitted to
dodge it with one little move
and then and then the interviewer is
going to move on he's not going to he's
not going to press the issue
and so they're simply unprepared for
any kind of real real questioning and
these were really really basic
uh good questions a question like okay
what would you have actually done
differently you can criticize
trump's response to the coronavirus what
would you have actually done that he
didn't do
doesn't want to answer that question
number three speaking of uh
speaking of msnbc and
people on there nancy pelosi was on
msnbc yesterday and
here's how that went we have these fires
in california
and in the west of 16 people have died
in washington
oregon and california including a
firefighter and a one-year-old baby
we our firefighters have been so very
very courageous
now we're again breaking records mother
earth is angry she's
telling us whether she's telling us with
hurricanes on the gulf coast
fires in the west whatever it is that
the climate crisis
is real and has an impact and of course
we can assume
uh no follow-up on that either no
question like
speaker pelosi how long have you been a
pagan
can you tell us more about your paganism
that'd be a good question
because the idea that mother earth is
angry
angry at us and is now creating
hurricanes and fires to punish us
is pure paganism it's a perfect example
of the kind of thing they can get away
with saying on msnbc
without any follow-up mother earth is
angry at us and is creating fires that's
really what you believe
well this is this is pure paganism it
really is
uh and it goes to show that
the the religiosity is a real need that
we have it's ingrained in us
as human beings and so if you reject
uh christianity if as nancy pelosi has
rejected her supposed catholic faith
uh she goes to paganism as many
democrats have and are now essentially
mother earth gaia worshipers but
remember always remember this is the
pro-science side
yes pro-science people who believe that
men can get pregnant women have penises
babies aren't people and mother earth
makes fires when she's angry at us for
driving suvs
pure unadulterated science
number four the new york post has an
interesting article looking quote inside
the privileged lives of protesters
busted for rioting in manhattan and
here's a look at the subjects of the
articles you can see the mugshots here
uh a little rough let's be honest not
the best angle on these guys
it's a mug shot you can't blame them it
but you know if i was a privileged
rioter i would have a personal stylist
with me at all times so that when i get
arrested maybe they can come in and just
do a little little touch-up
just run over you know fix me up a
little bit i mean your mugshot it's a
big moment it's gonna be with you for
the rest of your life
anytime somebody googles you that's
gonna pop up
so it's gonna be there forever they
should really give you a chance to comb
your hair
i think put on some makeup whether
you're a girl or guy
no judgment here no discrimination that
one guy there um uh
the one one over from the top on the
left he appears to have some sort of
dead or perhaps hibernating um
animal uh some kind of woodland creature
on top of his head he should have been
allowed to take that off in my opinion
so but anyway here's here let's go to
the article uh it says
the so-called revolutionaries who were
busted for rioting at a new african
black panther party rally
took a break from their yacht club lives
and modeling careers to be a part of the
mayhem
yes these are members of the black
panther party
apparently they certainly don't make
black panthers the way they they used to
is all i could say
the seven comrades including wealthy
upper state east sider clara crabber
had the mugshots tweeted out by the nypd
early wednesday
days after their arrests they were
cuffed during a protest organized by the
panthers and the revolutionary
abolitionist movement
groups condemning the death of daniel
prude who was killed while in custody
of the rochester police department in
march aside from crabber the redhead
daughter of an architect and child
psychiatrist with a second home in
connecticut
five of the others arrested appear to
also come from privileged backgrounds
um frank furmeister oh okay wait
clara crabber and frank furmeister
all right those are really are the
police sure that these are their real
names and not
not uh not fake names that sounds like
the kind of name you would just make up
on the spot if the cops are asking you
what's my name uh it's uh frank
fernmeister
smith frank fermice no frank furmeister
actually is a frederick firm i mean
frank furmeister uh fermi
yeah that's my name anyway it says that
frank furmeister charged with uh
rioting and possession of a graffiti
instrument is a freelance art director
who's designed ads for joe coffee and
has also worked for pepsi samsung and
the glenn levitt
he studied fine arts with a
concentration in photography at florida
state college
uh blah blah blah blah okay so you get
the idea these are all a bunch of
privileged brats
no big surprise there this really this
goes back to the point i made uh before
about these protests that
they are expressions of extreme
decadence more than anything else these
are privileged
privileged comfortable people uh
searching for a struggle searching for
a form of suffering um an oppression to
make their lives meaningful
we just as people we we it's very
difficult for us to
simply be comfortable and live in luxury
and admit that that's our lives
you'd think it'd be easy but it's not we
we need to have some sort of struggle
something to overcome
and i think there are so many people in
our country who live lives of such
unending comfort and all of us in fact
every single one of us no matter what
our socioeconomic situation is we all
are or almost all of us are absurdly
comfortable
in comparison to almost everyone else
who has ever lived
on planet earth uh that's just a
reflection of
of modern society and because of that
you've got a lot of people who are
desperate to
you know find meaning and some sort of
struggle to invent some kind of
uh you know boogeyman for them to fight
against
and i think that's a lot of what we're
seeing with these writings
the riots and the looting and antifa and
everything else
number five finally in our most
important story today as you know i've
always been a critic of dogs
i think dogs generally take take more
than they give they are needy emotional
high maintenance it's like having a
teenager in the home i guess except one
that craps on the carpet and eats your
couch
um but there are a few good dogs out
there
even i must admit and here's one right
here watch
the police
[Music]
i mean look on the bright side at least
he wasn't facing the other direction
that would have been
things can always be worse i guess is
what we learned from that
but that dog right there is a dog who
makes himself useful
so many dogs are called good dogs though
they have not earned the title
that dog though that's a good dog
good dog well done well done
thank you for your service well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt
walsh show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content